everyone and please be patient as I
start our LinkedIn live stream
it'll take just a moment
for future we are
going to be moving to the zoom platform
for webinars but today we're still on
our
WebEx platform which is
little cranky
and
there we go
all right
and Welcome to our LinkedIn live
audience our WebEx audience our YouTube
live streaming audience
um and we're here today with so much
Treme who is the general manager in
global
PRC lead of mindtree and the digital
security practice
and we're talking today about why cyber
security
it could be your next career move in
2023
so just a couple things before we get
our our conversation started but first
um if you are on WebEx you can quick
Summit uh questions for someone in the Q
a panel
and we'll get to those toward the end of
the session
uh if you are on the live streams you
can put questions into your comment or
chat boxes and you should be able to
have somebody pass those on to us so
um
we are going to ask
a poll question
at the beginning and another at the end
so let me
cue this up
our poll question is
as you can see how many years of
experience do you have you're on the
streaming services you can put your
answers in the chat
um but we'd just like to get an idea of
a kind of
variation in the audience so
we also asked the second question how
you're doing because over the last
several years during lockdowns and
surges and
pandemics and everything else that's
happened people have been under a lot of
psychological stress so we like to check
in with you about that
supposed to pull in about five seconds
so the poll results
and a bimodal distribution summit of
about 40 percent of the folks who are
still in uh college or university and uh
who ends of the two ends of the spectrum
exactly the 40 who are greater than five
years so it's a big interesting talk for
both audiences
and I'm going to let you just introduce
yourself describe yourself to the
audience
that better than I
thank you
is a very small introduction that I
shall I have of myself I have been
working with industry for the last 22
years having graduated in the year 2000
I've walked in companies like ACL web
Pro BW3
and a last part of my career has been
repeatedly with the India around nine to
ten years
but I usually divide my career into two
parts so in cyber security or in the
domain of information they would always
understand there are two sides of the
table right so one side is a practice
site where you practice the subject as a
cyber security practitioner you could be
an advisor he could be a consultant so
it could be a system integrator okay but
that's a practice site the other side is
the consumption site where you consume
fiber Security Services being the cyber
security or the information security
leadership of the company okay so I have
been on both the sides so on the
practice side I have been with uh
pwp mostly and IBM on the consumption
side I have been at resource even for
information security officer with a nbst
company with uh one of the service
delivery arms of PWC also uh in Wipro so
I have uh clearly equal amounts of
experience on both the two sides and I
think today that these two kind of
experiences helped me so today whatever
I'm going to speak about is will come
from these two diverse experiences
okay
all right let's let's get into our
discussion then um so
we're curious to know
first off there was a question from the
audience so you can you lay a just a
foundation of what cyber security covers
in
current world we live in we've we've
been through
the pandemic we've been through the
transition to non-contact and work from
home and all of the things that took
digital transformation and put it into
hyperdrive and so that plus the fact
that so much of our Lives has lived on
mobile devices and you kind of just a
give a that kind of Baseline for what
cyber security covers today
will the boundaries of cyber security
have definitely expanded over the last
few years and especially both the
pandemic so uh when I started my career
in 2000 it used to be called network
security network security is to be all
so there were firewalls and nutrition
detection systems and antiviruses so if
you now bracket them you will understand
the network firewall intuition detection
on iteration product prevention system
or even fire or even antiviruses are
more on the network they could decide
gradually systems evolved okay it became
more of infrastructure security okay
then all kinds of information came in it
became more of information security Now
with uh the digitization the rapid
progress of digitization is more called
moral fiber or digital security so with
the overall Crux remain same whatever
data or information that I have
I need to protect
so like all the jewelries and ornaments
that you have in your house I have
certain targets to protect and my target
is my data
or information and this could also be my
reputation everything so those I need to
protect how I protect and from whom I
protect is all about cyber security Now
data is registered okay so cyber
security is not limited to only digital
but because digital is so big in our
lives like the female or webinar itself
it's a digital way of learning right we
if they go left to a classroom and go
more to a digital classroom like you can
play learn right so similarly the
digital is so big in our life so it's
more of digital security than rather
physical security but anyway that's also
part of it uh
so digital security domain has increased
and now it is part of our daily life
previously used to be the domain of an
Enterprise or a company okay a company
says that uh I have certain assets to
protect and I need cyber security but
the same feeling now also comes to an
individual like you and me
out there the practitioner even me
really a regular lives with her family
right we go to a club we go to the
shopping mall we go for groceries we use
apps to download and to I mean to use
for daily lives
our daily life is not digital that cyber
security has permitted into the daily
life because my information is now out
everywhere it's out on the internet and
some of my information is actually very
sensitive in nature could be private in
nature okay so my information about
myself is so much out of the internet I
need to protect myself okay so that's my
digital security as an individual as a
human being as a social at the same time
I am also responsible for protecting the
information of my company the company
that I represent organization that I
represent so that it's more of
Enterprise so cyber security is like
everywhere
thank you
um and it you you made me think of the
fact that
um there's a couple of things that have
leaked into our popular culture
um we never would have thought
even 10 years ago that people would say
I've been hacked
as if it was something that happened to
them
in their person in their in their own
body
um but if your information's been
compromised or if you're
um Persona online has been compromised
it feels like a personal intrusion
um and it is in many ways and then the
other is that that terminology has been
become so pervasive that we have people
talking about life hacks as if the there
is a a way to apply the the notion of of
hacking or or tweaking a system and
applying that to everything that we do
in our our real world lives so that's a
it's an interesting world that we we
live in today that um people of my
generation
he never saw a company when we started
out um
what are some of the trends that you see
coming up we talked a little bit about
the fact that the pandemic forced
acceleration of digital transformation
what do we see coming ahead in 2023
so the pandemic has reduced the brown
boundaries
previously a company had a Digital
Boundary a Digital Boundary was very
very experimented at the perimeter there
used to be a firewall typically of
corporate firewall we should block
traffic or allow traffic based on
certain predefined policy it's like a
yes or no if if the condition is met the
traffic is allowed if the condition is
not made the traffic is not allowed so
they're the gatekeeper who stands at the
boundary and lets the good guys in and
the bad guy is out okay now the the the
overall premise of this thing was that
trust is restricted within the boundary
which means that within the boundary the
level of trust is higher than outside
the boundary because the guys who you're
coming in from outside are less trusted
but when these inside they are more
trusted so trust was always higher
inside than outside that is how it
worked okay but nowadays it doesn't work
that way because zero trust has saved us
to say that I really don't know
foreign so I will not trust anyone or
rather I will distract everyone
I will distrust everyone and verify
everyone
okay so I do not even trust the data
inside my boundary anymore I do not
trust the people the identities inside
my boundary anymore okay so I do not
know where they have come from I do not
trust them anymore the whole pattern is
shifted to uh mechanism of zero track
where I do not trust anyone but verify
everyone with authentication
authorization
Etc
so so
digital security cyber security is going
to be more identity based previously it
used to be a network based then it
became more of a system based okay
gradually we have seen that identity the
whole idea of identity that defines
cyber security and identity could be a
network element it could be a server it
could be a user it could be anybody A
supplier a third party but that's
identity how he or she is known inside
the system that is my identity and I
will now Benchmark everyone on the basis
of identity so cyber security is going
to be heavily identity based
okay that makes sense in in in
as you talked about zero trust you
reminded me of uh an episode in history
where uh President Ronald Reagan was
speaking about
um strategic arms talks with the Soviet
Union and he quoted a Russian proverb
trust but verify and so now you're
describing it in an environment where
don't trust and verify is more of the
rule so that that um
there's there's another example from uh
from the Cold War I happen to enjoy
history a little bit and there was a
film called Fail-Safe and one of the
concepts in the film was that a uh
American Air crew uh being sent on a
mission to bomb the Soviet Union
uh erroneously
um could not receive a command even from
the president of the United States to
return because they didn't know if they
could trust the order not to be a big
one from the enemy so this is uh the
same type of problem that we now have
where you can't trust that an email that
you get from your boss is really an
email from your boss unless you have
verified that through the security
systems in your organization so
um
when you're talking about careers in
cyber security what are some of the the
career paths that you can
recommend to people who either enter the
this field from
from college or they enter this field
from a pivot from another Direction in
technology
okay
assuming I have I mean there are people
from all age groups out here from all
levels of experience like I see some
college or university some people have
more than five years of experience this
is really one thing cyber security is
not aesthetic subject
okay so what I tell today may not hold
tomorrow because bite between the 24
hours of today and tomorrow some new
technology will come and some new attack
would have been developed Okay so cyber
security is constantly a moving Target
so but can you cope up with this it's
really difficult
so don't though the target is moving
don't go on running after the target all
the time
what I'm saying is that uh there are
certain carriers in cyber security which
makes sense today some of them might not
make sense tomorrow and some of these
were not available maybe two years back
but let me tell you like cyber security
analysts network security engineer
incident response analyst
then
iot security mobile security analyst or
secure coder okay so these are from the
starting points where you can start your
domain your journey in fiber security
okay like a programmer now most of us
because of the proliferation of IIT
services in India and elsewhere we end
up in companies like we provide for this
HCL where which are large IIT services
companies okay but
in cyber security when you will
understand a cyber product or an
application you understand that a much
of the security it comes from inside
the how the program how the product has
been created or programmed so then they
will soon understand that if you learn
to code securely you will be able to
make a more secure product
okay so all the fiber products all the
computer applications or apps or mobile
apps or whatever we see have coded
securely so there's definitely a large
carrier in Secure coding
okay now which is now called devop div
fake off
and if the copy is slightly different
because security is getting into the
development cycle initially it was only
a development cycle now security is
getting
into the beginning of the development
cycle is called shift left so deep check
up so difficult is a very hot carry
option okay so people who start with
programming and definitely after some
time moving to devops and difficults
kind of career that's one
cyber security one more hot carrier
option cyber security is incident
response
because of the multitude of breaches and
attacks you need to respond to them
right so their influence all the time
okay now incident response is a scale
that requires a lot of other variety of
Health okay you don't gather the skills
in a day but incident response uh if are
definitely one of the favorite carrier
options the cyber security in these
rates now whatever I am saying what what
all carrier options are giving me to
understand that most of these are
supplemented by are by strong
certification okay so if you want to
demonstrate to the world that you are
truly a death account guy you may want
to go in for a difficult kind of
certification if you want to show that
you are uh
good efficient incident Handler incident
responder you should go for insulin
response certification supported by
companies like uh science SN right so
cyber security now as you grow up the
ladder as they grow up the ladder of
cyber security will understand that the
origin is getting stretched so you are
no more an engineer your normal analyst
you are no more uh incident Handler you
become more of a
information security manager or cyber
security architect so those roles are
gradually up the ladder okay an
architect uh designer system designer
then in function security manager cyber
security manager and the fiso Chief
Information Security Officer these roles
are gradually up the ladder so
definitely is a progression in cyber
security and that is how it happens
great that that's a a great overview or
roadmap for for people to to look ahead
toward
um one of the things that I took from
what you were saying is that uh because
the field is fluid
um you've got to be prepared to
adjust your career path or pivot a bit
depending on what it where you started
and where you're going right now you may
end up
needing to make a investment or a turn
into some other area of cyber security
I'll give an example I started my career
with the maintenance of a firewall
back in 2000 uh checkpoint used to
dominate the network firewall Market
checkpoint was good unfortunate and
checkpoint firewall it was for version
4.1 and then it came checkpoint 2000 or
something like that right and at that
point of time I did a certification
called CCA checkpoint certified security
I can see it or figure Engineers
okay sales checkpoint was hot at the
point of time or rather firewall Market
was hot I decided to supplement my
experience with a firewall certification
but soon firewalls became more of a norm
now nobody talks about firewall it is
considered a norm it's considered like
you have a light and a fan in your room
it's considered like that so people do
not need a viral engineer anymore number
one okay and the skill of firewall
management has got into an overall
larger bucket and nowaday firewalls are
more available in a managed service mode
where a service provider is providing
the firewall as a service okay so a lot
of the roles have changed so back so
what I'm saying back in 2000 I used to
be a viral engineer I could not have
continued that line after five or six
years okay I have changed because the
market have changed so you need to
confidently evolve and move with the
market
and and that implies another aspect
which is to be uh
flexible and Broad in your skill base
and we talk about you know the common
term in uh funding and development is
the t-shaped uh expert where you have a
broad range of skills in a particular
field and then you develop skills in one
aspect of that field to become The
Specialist or expert but that broad
range gives you the ability then to
gradually migrate if field changes
for example you need to move from
firewalls to intrusion General intrusion
detection or things like that then you
have that base of skills that gives you
that ability another aspect of that I'm
going to ask you to comment on in a
moment but it's one thing I wanted to
mention is
if you are a specialist or if you are
starting off in a particular role having
the ability to understand the other
aspects and roles that are in the field
is important because you're going to be
part of a team of people and people will
be coming to you with I need a
requirement that in your area
your ability to understand why they're
asking for that and how it fits into the
bigger picture within your organization
always going to be
making gonna make you a stronger
practitioner and contributor right but
can you comment on that right so while
you may start your career with a
particular field or domain okay and you
are partnering that for some time and
see all at the at all points in time we
can't control our career I must say that
okay you don't have a total control over
your career so you may get a job today
which is a particular job so that shaped
the career for that point of time right
so now suppose you get got a job in a
security Operation Center as a another
level one level one analyst fantastic
opportunity as a level analyst you will
be responsible for analyzing the fiber
ticket incidents understanding why it
happens may we coordinate with the L2
analyst respond to that incident right
go on doing that at the same time
parallelly go on perfume certifications
but certification is never going to
become a replacement or alternate for
experience experience accounts much much
more our certification will just top it
up like an ice cream okay so as you put
future carrier and you pursue
certifications to demonstrate your
knowledge of that you gradually broaden
out so in a sock in a security Operation
Center because why I'm saying about a
sock because today many cyber security
roles are available in a shop because
soft is a large service private security
service which is consumed which is
provided and consumed right and I saw a
typical thought from a large company
will employ a lot of people maybe eat a
single possession or a batch will employ
100 people so maybe it's working across
three batches it can have 300 people
Okay so
look at the other rules of the talk
application security
so you will have people who are pursuing
application security threaten
availability management kind of roles
who are assessing the threats in an
application and then trying to remediate
them okay that's an application faculty
role okay look at incident response okay
look at threat hunting look at proactive
State hunting pet hunting is a
supplement software intelligence okay
let's say something is a activity which
you do on the Deep Web and the dark web
okay it requires you a different kind of
skills so if you're in a sock
fortunately I'll call that a fortune try
to broaden out the more kinds of diverse
roles you try to gather your vision and
Horizon of Private Security will become
more and more complete otherwise you'll
remain stuck to only a incident response
engineer okay so if you're aiming for a
CSO if you're aiming for this party
ticket fat money rolls okay which you
think will give you a lot of money in
the future you need to have knowledge of
everything
you may not end up being a master of
everything okay but you may be a master
of one and you have knowledge of
everything but unless you have a
knowledge of everything you can look at
the bigger picture from the top you
can't go to the top
so to become a massive so information
security manager cyber security head uh
whatever these roles are leadership
roles you need to understand application
security network security infrastructure
security Cloud security you need to
understand every of them and how they
all talk to each other in creating a
risk posture for the organization this
risk that this this is the risk that you
now need to take into the leadership and
present to the leadership because this
is my risk and this is what I need to
reduce
the Coalition of all the risks from all
the different domains into one thing of
it is what you have to do at the Go of
the ladder
and and as you pointed out earlier the
you know the risks come from inside and
from outside the
the example of a
a battleship
and how you protect the battleship well
you the first thing you do is you make
sure it's well armored the next thing
you do is you look at all points of
vulnerability where it might be
vulnerable to attack and then the third
thing you do is you make sure that it's
accompanied by the defensive systems
that look for enemies and Tech attacks
and and
support those attacks before they
actually get to the battleship so
um we saw that in popular culture in the
movie Star Wars where
indestructible death star was taken down
by a
an attack through one of its garbage
exhaust ports so
this is where you you
and and there was a security analyst on
board who said we've analyzed their
attack sir and we think that there is a
danger so
um this is the the kind of environment
that that looking at you need to be able
to
understand both from internal and
external where the where the threats
exist
um even if your role is limited to one
small aspect you'll still be uh
future and as you move up into more
rules of responsibility you need to
understand
um all the dimensions of the threat
surface so one more one more thing rules
these plates are very much
technology-based okay so when I talk of
a role a data security engineer a data
security engineer would be working on a
data security solution could be a data
leakage prevention DLP kind of relation
could be a data classification Collision
could be a data leveling solution okay
but data security engineer would be
working on a technological solution
which lets you protect the data okay so
an identity engineer would work on
identity management solution an item or
IM solution okay or at Android Engineers
will be working on a privileged identity
management solution like PM or bam okay
so why I'm saying this is that your role
means that your role today is based on a
solution based on technology okay so
when I look at a person and look at a
resource I will first want to know what
technology bringing to the table okay
suppose we're implementing uh privileged
identity management solution in the
company team based on Cyber Arc suppose
for example okay so I need someone or
rather team of people to control and to
operate or run the solution okay take
actions because our solution will pick
up a lot of incidents you create a lot
of incidents so so I need people on
Incident Management okay so I need
people who know the solution the
technology can respond to an incident
and
come back okay so I'll I may require a
identity management solution who knows
the solution I may require a risk
engineer who who will re-canalyst Who
will understand the risk out of it so
but at the end of the day almost all the
roles are heavily technology solution
based
does that make sense that does bring up
a question about
um
whether somebody who wants to move into
the into this field at the entry level
whether they need to be
um skilled as a programmer or
other
skills more important
very difficult question I understand for
everyone and I understand meaning maybe
many people who have this question
uh
programming experience always helps so
if you're coming from a programming
background or if you're coming from a
system and this in background any
opportunity to have that please continue
with that cyber security graduate will
automatically fall on your platter you
can't avoid it support you today on Unix
administrator your or your software
material or something or a cloud VM
administrator okay today you can't
operate or you can't manage a VM a
virtual machine without cyber security
you can't do that so stay being a VM
administrator but whatever cyber
security thing option you're getting try
to grab it up okay so what I'm saying is
that don't be too pushy don't take hasty
decisions whatever you have you can
always make certain good out of it it is
not something that don't have this
feeling oh what I have got it's not
enough it's not adequate I mean there's
a continual feeling of this content
management whatever you have can be
utilized can be leveraged can be
exploited okay so suppose uh if anybody
tells me that the boss I am doing this I
can can tell you I can tell you a path
where continuing to do that you can
still become a cyber security expert
okay you can you tell me any profit or
any role okay you don't have to switch
switching does not always help because
switching comes with a lot of cost okay
so whatever you're doing please enjoy
that
get into certifications now I understand
that when I say certification people
will ask for certification yes some
certifications are golden in nature like
CH c h is always a very good
certification to do Cloud security
separation like ccsk and C C HP are good
certifications to do okay or rather cisp
is more of a supervisory kind of a
certification where it comes it should
come ideally at the latest stage of a
carrier where you understood the overall
subject and then you can attempt to cisp
so if you attempt cssp within the first
or second year of your career and then
come to my table saying so much I'm a
theater speed I may not take you because
though you have maybe your cssp you do
not have the experience to correlate
with the learning of the cisp Okay so
every certification comes with the right
amount of experience to go with it it's
a marriage
okay so certain notifications are
married to experience please respect
that
yeah that's an excellent point and then
that there is
generally a natural progression that
from the
outside of your career you're when you
Embark upon entering the field of cyber
security and how you move through it and
up the of the chain of understanding
that the different areas and then
integrating that into said The more
supervisory type of role and then moving
up into management type of positions so
um when you look at that kind of uh a
road map
what are some of the things you can
recommend to our audience for
uh putting those plans into action to be
able to take those first steps where
where can
where can they go or what what can they
do in order to qualify for that first
role in cyber security
okay so if you're coming into cyber
ticket with zero experience then
definitely the only weapon you have is a
certification okay demonstrate your
knowledge because they don't have
experience
though personally I would like to take
someone with more experience but for all
the people who are intent who are
jumping to get into cyber security
without experience definitely you have
to take the help of a enabler called
certification so now talking about
certification which one will you do so
if you remember initially I had said
that incident response is a very hot
subject the states
so in the subject of Internet response
there are some cool certifications go to
files you will find out a lot of cool
certification instant response okay
in the field of applique application
security they are not too much
authentications most of them are product
certifications okay but if you are
looking at overall certification for
cyber security go for CH okay 35 ethical
hacker a certified ethical hacker does
not really make you an hacker
okay
but it will give you an idea of how to
protect system
right so so CH is always a golden
certification
now uh cloud is very important but see I
mean with the with the Advent of azure
and uh AWS and gcp certifications on
online you got any point of time you can
do the certification but I think if you
do not understand Cloud why the cloud
basically in place how do the cloud work
you can not correlate the learning or
verification so cloud is important go
for certification like ccsk or ccsp okay
but a later stage getting to Cloud start
working on a cloud start reading about
cloud and gradually get into a ccsk or
CC HP kind of that image
excellent
um we had as you saw a number of people
who are still at University
um
ask an interesting question uh at least
I think it's a nurse question is what
kinds of courses
at University
um can help people prepare for
um moving into this career when they
graduate okay I think India has been
fantastic strides in this field in the
last two or three years okay this was a
really vulnerable area in the Indian
education system but now we have almost
covered the gap so if you do a simple
search on Google uh which colleges or
university in India offer PHP in cyber
security you'll find out I think around
200 okay cyber security as as a THC
Bachelor of Science okay Unthinkable few
years back okay so there are many
institutes which now offer a BAC in
cyber security there are many ones which
offer a big take also in cyber security
we take previously used to be restricted
to computer science to instrumentation
to electronics Power Electronics and
mechanical people all the stuff but now
the institutes which are for a beta
conference cyber security and then you
have these iits and the triple its own
in conjunction with institutes like
simply learn and other organizations
offer Advanced diploma or executive
courses and cyber security so as I said
the
the timing of the course in your career
is very important if you ask me at this
point in time when I walk for 22 years I
will go for an executive course in cyber
security from some MBA or a technical
institute but the course is executive in
the nature that it teaches me more to
talk to the board of the company
leadership of the company okay but for
people who are just graduating you
should get into
security or even if you have not been
fortunate enough you can do a one-year
postal course or one year correspondence
online courses cyber security Now
I mean the digital learning institutes
are all over many of them have got this
cyber security courses in in
collaboration with large American
universities also which are offered on a
business planning like in order to come
for that
thank you
um
and we're reaching a point I think I'm
looking at the clock where we can start
taking questions from the audience
because I think that um there's going to
be quite a few I've got a few that I saw
early in the webinar so let me
uh address a couple of that
um we had a
audience member who asked if forensic
people can do MSC cyber security so
could you explain what what that
question's about and
answer that question once again
the question was can forensic people do
MSC cyber security so I guess I'm not
sure if they're asking about a masters
of science or if there's another another
term that they're request asking about
rather iot the opposite or the reverse
Direction okay forensic is an advanced
form of cyber security for cyber
security incident and fraud
investigation it requires a different
kind of skills okay but foreign
security and system security so if you
have done a bacu or a masters in cyber
security and then approach forensics I
think that route would be more
preferable or more logical or reasonable
okay
um we had one definition question uh
user called Young Thing asked
what is proxychain
what is proxy
proxy chain are you familiar with that
sir yeah proxy and I familiar but in
that uh career related question proxy
well I think they just asked they were
just curious to know what it was
so so probably changed
you know what are the property for is
the web proxy or email property internet
proxy you know what the property do we
receive the properties uh like chained
or bound to one after the other okay so
let's not get into that but uh it's not
it's not a subject related question over
here okay
um and
we had a question from sumik who uh has
a background in finance and Taxation and
a Professional Services firm
um
and
previously had gotten a B Tech in civil
engineering
so what are some of the things that that
uh Puma should study or look to pick up
before he switches into cyber security
okay finally want to quickly come into
cyber security and I am assuming that
you don't have too much of time because
your background is we take in I think
what whatever the be taken
um civil engineering civil engineering
now a quick Grant course and cyber
security might help you to come into the
change direction okay so while you're
while you are working uh based on your
knowledge of based on your experience
sorry based on qualification of be taken
level engineering okay you can do a one
year course on cyber security from some
of the large institutes okay which could
be done digitally and based on that you
can come into the field of hybrid
security don't do a specialized code
this is only for the person who will ask
this question don't do a specialized
course like internet response or
application security or iot or mobile
security because someone who is from
civil engineering if I am a recruiter
and if I have a candidate who is a civil
engineer I would not rather
having a watch expensive knowledge of
the subject maybe not very deep but I
would want him to understand the overall
subject so do a overall statistics cyber
security and not a specialized firm
because only for that person without
paying him question
okay
um
asks a question he is almost 40 has
moved from network security into q a and
would like now to Pivot back into cyber
security
um what are the I think new things that
um
you should consider in his
platting out that switch
or that pivot
I I think I understood that the person
is in network security already right
uh from network security I thought this
is an original background here fine
carry on that's fantastic I mean if your
native security that's a fantastic field
to be you don't have to switch
what I said in the morning or what I
said earlier I'll repeat don't push
don't push don't always be unhappy with
what you have if you're a network
security please continue network
security there's a fantastic place to be
because network security is the
foundation for the video transition is
the foundation for Revenue trust is
definitely on application Network I need
everything but network security plays
are very important and key role for the
attraction it's a foundation for sassy
okay we just found the key Technologies
right now okay so please stay with
network security do a certification
which will which cover enter the entire
cyber security not only Network so that
will kind of give the message to a
higher a recruiter okay this guy has got
specialized network security but he has
got a horizon on cyber security that is
the kind of rather prefer to hire
don't push
all right
um illusion asked a question about uh
what is your opinion of people who are
self-taught that is to say that they've
pursued various certifications even
though they don't have a formal degree
um is that somebody who you would
consider
yes and no
so
does not uh choose to satisfy himself on
this any of the commercially available
certification okay so I am understanding
I assume that his knowledge is fantastic
but how do they demonstrate his
knowledge he has to demonstrate The
Benchmark with the reference right so at
the end of the day when he writes is
really and or his uh
biodata and what would you write he's
really like knowledge but then someone
would have to demonstrate the knowledge
right so a cyber security certification
on any kind of formal education
demonstrates your knowledge so I would
say uh the way the industry works right
now at this point of time uh I I mean
it's difficult to only Survive by way of
self-taught but it is fantastic way to
start B cells thought because that is
giving a fantastic background but also
gradually start up to start doing formal
courses from the subject to demonstrate
what you know okay I think that also
addresses the question that came from
Tanya because she asked
um
if a degree is necessary to work in
cyber security if the alternative is to
take various classes and certifications
to gain that knowledge and
demonstrate that knowledge yes it is
necessary when I'm a hiring manager and
I've got Apple 13 by application 10 TVs
on my table okay
maybe the theory of propose anything can
be fantastic here I mean he has done
everything Hands-On and maybe he's an
ethical hacker I mean he has done a lot
of research and whatever but how would I
know what he's doing what he has done
only a certification or a knowledge or a
qualification proves what he has done I
will not say that is the best judgment
or the best the archic of judging but
that actually uh kind of kind of tells
you what he has done okay when I've got
10 CVS and I need to take look at one or
two I'll go definitely for the one which
are more qualified okay and then I'll
verify that
okay
um
so having the degree is
one of those things where you have
demonstrated that you have the
discipline and you have the broad
background that came with that study and
that that is gives you kind of an uh
platform underneath your your career so
um
there are people as some of the folks in
the audience have mentioned there are
people they know who have succeeded
without a degree but your your advice is
a degree is going to give you a
significant advantage
of the largest companies of the world
many of them don't have a formal
education but though that's a fantastic
example and we'd all have them as Role
Models understand they are very few in
number
we are look we are talking of them
because they are few because there's
only one CEO of support say Google or
whatever there's only one key of company
okay so we are looking at the examples
because they are only unique unique the
energy is unique okay but most of the
people and I am definitely uh
The Cure that you can succeed with only
uh self-started knowledge okay but then
when it is in a completely World outside
and your CV has to be judged among
others I think qualifications will help
um
we have silver who has he's a tcna
network engineer
um and is curious to know what kinds of
platforms are
important to know about he's talking
about things like Linux
different fireworld Technologies and
that type of thing what types of
platforms and tools does he need to be
aware of in the current environment
if you're talking of tools I cannot name
one tool because private security is
about 1001 tools okay you can't end you
can't end your day you want to end your
career learning tools okay do you learn
one tool even in suppose in the field of
identity management item I am or Android
management there are thousand one tool
itself there are companies every day
we're coming up with you and new tool
okay how much will you learn
more basic is a concept and why do you
get the concept from okay basic
fundamental notifications as I say cah
is a fundamental notification okay cssp
at a higher level at an intermediate or
higher level is a fundamental
certification always go for fundamental
certification which give you uh overall
knowledge of the subject
then go for Tool based certifications
two-way certifications is more situation
based is more need based is is a more uh
maturity if we have requirement of the
tool then only the tool certification
will come in handy but otherwise I'll
always rely on a guy who has got node or
knowledge of the fundamental
yeah
and I think that you know in the the
topic of what platforms to be aware of
you
the platforms are constantly evolving
and changing so you need to be flexible
in that area right does that is that
correct
yes yes so today today you have cloud
and I know everybody's raving about
three Cloud platforms because they are
the majority I mean I mean there are
five other things Cloud platform and
three of them are the larger one okay WF
as your and uh Google
since these three
contribute to 90 of the cloud Market or
the cloud service provider Market CSP
market and one or two the two of them
have got larger share than the other it
makes sense because
Azure or AWS or GTP is thought of
becoming a benchmark it become a
reference point so when people say are
you a cloud engineer people does not say
you're a cloud engineer or they say are
even AWS certified Cloud engineer or
even as your certified Cloud engine
engineer that is what people say because
these Technologies are the only two or
three Technologies in the world right
now okay but as more technology will
come it will not be limited to AWS
Revenue anymore okay
so what is relevant today may not be
relevant tomorrow
yeah that makes sense
um
we have a question from John who asks
I think he's graduating from uh what we
would call in the U.S high school it's a
12 class
um and he wants to know
how he would
um study to
get certified as a certified ethical
hacker
what types of uh program for training
can you take
yeah get into training get into any
Institute who offered a 35 ethical
hacker program
please make sure that the program The
Learning is accompanied by lab exercises
real harmonic exercises because
otherwise there is no value to the eh
program okay so so many institutes offer
I think it will learn also offer th okay
but and but if there are lab exercises
or real demo exercises it makes more
sense
okay
um
taking a look to see if the because
we're getting to the end of the question
period
so here is a kind of philosophical
question which is a good one from
um
asks
in in the environment we're in currently
as as artificial intelligence and
machine learning become more prevalent
and capable
um
how does that impact cyber security will
the machines be able to secure
themselves or will human beings always
be needed to supervise that process
cyber security is going to be one of the
largest consumers of machine learning
okay
concept called cyber immunity
a little one minute on that so what is
your human immunity what is your bio
immunity by unity is a process where the
body automatically responds to unknown
threats and kills itself
because at any point given point of time
you you I'm sure your body is attacked
by a lot of viruses and bacteria but
your body is able to fight it off
because of biological immunity which you
have when it fails that is why it
becomes a fever or some disease or
something or covered or whatever fails
but before that the body has already put
up a fight understand that okay that
fight is because of your biological
immunity
when you equate that in the fiber world
you have cyber immunity the Cyber
immunity is an autonomous way of
responding to an unknown cyber threat
autonomous and how does my autonomous
response come in and autonomous means
that my body or the system or the target
will autonomously or by itself respond
without human detection without human
intervention
so if a inanimate object has to
autonomously respond to a thyroid that
means there has to be a lot of
intelligence built into it based on
which it can take a decision right so
Ai and ml is going to have impact cyber
security in such a way a lot of cyber
mundane jobs are becoming not only will
become automated not only the automated
means they'll become more consistent
regular and automated okay but fiber
immunity will gradually benefit more
from Ai and ml so don't fear your cyber
security jobs are not going to go away
with more a and ml
and the example of uh comparing machine
immunity to human immunity is great
because in human immunity one of the
mechanisms is uh that when your body
encounters a new type of antigen or
foreign invader
your immune system doesn't know how to
deal with it at the very beginning but
once it learns that it's foreign and
potentially harmful it creates
antibodies so it programs itself
to attack that
Vader whenever again occurs and this is
why vaccines work because you get a
sample of what the disease
organism is and then your antibody is
performed so you can imagine that in
artificial intelligence and machine
learning will be used to create a system
where
a
a
cyber system
detects when something enters that is
foreign that is not part of the normal
operation and and the purpose of the
system and then creates its own ways of
repelling that so but that's uh that's a
little bit right the effective of this
will depend on data
yeah the better the quality of data the
better a decision is
because statistical model mathematical
models work on data if you if you give
flash a gibberish data the greater than
the gibberish okay so a cyber security
system which responds autonomously we
need tons and tons of data to analyze
under champ and then decide based on the
data so data is going to be the key so
people who are also a data analytics
industry click Rejoice data analysis is
also going to become a big consume I
mean type circuit is going to be a big
consumer of data analytics
okay
um we're reaching the time where uh I
have to unfortunately apologize to
everybody we had um I should
reveal that we had over 3 000 people
register for this webinar and uh many
hundreds attended so we have many more
questions unfortunately then we can make
time to answer
um but I do want to thank
um for the
the generous uh time and knowledge that
he shared with it with everyone
um and I'm going to uh share with you
his LinkedIn
profile if you want to reach out to him
and uh see if he can
connect with you but
um
and that will be
his election but I'm going to put this
into the chat box just to thank you make
it available to people
that's it
thank you and and
I've enjoyed this conversation immensely
some some except thank you pleasure
seeing you again
um I'm going to to close out the webinar
with a description of a
program that simply learn offers
and
is some referred to there you know you
find programs that are in conjunction or
in partnership with various universities
in India and in the US and elsewhere
this one happens to be
affiliated with MIT where MIT provides
some of the content in Esther classes
and it is a six-month program that
covers a broad range of skills
coming in from
Network app and device security
um
understanding the the hacker wine set
looking at the overall security posture
for an organization and then policy and
governance of cyber security and this
all culminates at the end of the six
months and
Capstone project where where you apply
the Hands-On learning you've learned
through that program into a
project where you're given a challenge
that you would get from a real world
employer in cyber security and you
design and Implement that solution so
and you do get the ability to take
master classes from MIT instructors
along the program so this is one of the
programs that we offer happens to be a
great one
um covers a number of different tools
again this
mentioned you don't want to focus too
much on particular tools because they're
shifting all the time but you do want to
know that you've gotten hands-on
experience
um solving problems during a program
like this so this is one of the ways we
do that there are live virtual classes
where you meet directly with the
instructors weekly and
can you ask them questions can watch
them go go through the exercises and
Concepts
so at the end you get two certifications
one is from Simply learned and that's
certifying that you completed the
program the other one is directly from
MIT which certifies that you've
completed their cyber security
governance program
and I just want to ask a quick question
about a level of Interest
people in the audience if
something you might think that this is
something you're interested in
just let us know and what time frame
you're looking to
begin training of this type
again this is not a commitment this is
just a informational or interest level
assessment
we'll leave that open for another
15-20 seconds here
you got about 10 seconds to get your
answer in
and
about half the audience said that they
are interested another 40 percent said
they may be interested
um and I'll give you uh information
about how to get in touch with us and
find out more about this
um and then about half said they want to
do it either right away or within the
next three months so
um again
we'll share with you how to contact us
is have this thank you slide up I'll go
into the chat and share with you the um
vertigo
hold on a moment
I will pull that up
lost it for a second I accidentally
closed the window
okay
please bear with me for just a moment
yeah
there we go
okay
I had it at my fingertips but then I
accidentally closed it this is the uh
email address that you can contact us
and also the URL for the program page
for the program I just described and we
also invite you to contact uh connect
with us on our
social media channels at simply learn on
Facebook Twitter simply learned on
LinkedIn
um
we would love to have you join us for
more of these informational webinars and
we'd also love to welcome you into our
learner community
and again
a very very heartfelt thanks to somac
for being here today
and uh sharing with you his
expertise and and experience in this
industry
and that concludes our webinar for today
thank you all for being here with us and
we look forward to seeing you again
thank you touch of luck